(reel rolling)
(beep)
♪ It was kind of rough. ♪
♪ I had an uphill battle ♪
♪ The doctor sat my parents down ♪
♪ And said my life was fragile ♪
♪ Respect is in the game ♪
♪ And Gary Vee the name ♪
♪ Just put your head
down and do the work ♪
♪ And everything will change ♪
♪ Sipping tea, help the field ♪
♪ Yeah that's what I wanted ♪
♪ Being patient, held the
trick if we're being honest ♪
♪ Tea with Gary Vee ♪
♪ Put you positivity, yeah ♪
- Hey, everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
Good to see everybody.
Happy to be here.
And just ready to rock and roll.
So let's rock and roll.
Let's get right into it.
- How's it going, Gary?
- What's good bro, how are you?
- I'm good, right, I watched
your live stream on TikTok
for the online challenge,
that was amazing.
- Thank you so much.
- It was so great to see
everybody come together so cool.
- What's cooking with you man?
- Not much just continuing to grind TikTok
'cause that's where the attention is,
but also trying to get people
over to YouTube and Instagram.
It's been going pretty well.
So just trying to spread
across all the platforms.
- I love that, what can I help you with?
- Yeah, so I have a question for you.
So how would a creator balance ambition
while also not over judging themselves?
- I think it's just having
a real conversation with yourself,
just really just going there.
Even the way you asked
that question, obviously,
you've been listening to enough of
either my themes or other themes
or you've got there yourself.
The reality is that ambition and patience
seem to be opposites,
but when blended together
really lead to a higher
level of happiness.
And so I couldn't push harder
for people to figure out
how to get there.
I think a lot of times when people think
they might be complacent
or not pushing hard enough
when they just need a
rest, and that's okay, too.
And so, actually I find
it easier now there.
I think it came natural to
me after years of practice,
but I think the fact that
that's even on your radar
is already a winning formula.
- Gotcha.
- The fact that you're even debating that
already puts you in a good spot.
- Yeah, I mean, I enjoy the process.
So I love the hustle.
I love working from the time I wake up
to till the time I go to bed, I enjoy it.
Yeah, just trying to figure
out that balance mentally,
not even so much in what I'm doing,
but more just, up here in the head.
- I get it.
- But yeah, and then any
advice for starting a business
with a family member,
'cause I know you've done stuff
with AJ and you're getting--
- On that one you just gotta make sure
that you value the person
more than the money
and the clout or respect.
It's a really challenging
game, family businesses.
But the reality is if you
could just love somebody
more than you love the money
or the clout, or the credit,
then you'll be in a good spot.
For me it was more credit.
It was more like, hey dad, hey AJ,
I'm a better businessman than you.
And that creates friction.
For them, I think they valued
the dollars a little bit more.
I don't judge that, I just
think they do more than me.
So that worked out a
little bit in the fact
that that's how that broke down with us.
But I think you've gotta figure out
if the person you're
going into business with
has the same ambitions as you do.
Is it money?
Is it the credit of who did it?
I think communication is
just everything in life,
and definitely in family businesses.
- Cool, thank you I appreciate that.
- You're welcome.
- What about some some
rapid fire questions.
- Oh yeah, Dustin we're doing this?
- Yes so this is our little
new segment called Small Tok.
Played after TikTok, obviously.
And Evans gonna ask you just
like a rapid fire of questions.
Specifically for like, I
guess our TikTok audience, so.
- Everybody's watching right now.
We're always trying to hack
and this is a very meta moment,
I talk a lot about put yourself
in a position to create content.
So Evan, thecardguy here
is crushing on TikTok.
So, we've been bringing friends
that we've interact with here,
90% kind of fans, 10%
kind of people we know,
and we layered on this concept
because we're going to chop
it and put it on to TikTok.
So, hopefully this will be entertaining
and more importantly we'll
see how we figure out
how to use it in TikTok.
So let's try it out.
- Okay, first question.
What in your opinion makes
a good content creator?
Like in just a few words.
- Lack of fear.
- Lack of fear, I like that, great.
Okay, who is the creator
that impresses you and why?
- Zach King, just 'cause
that shit is crazy.
Like, my brain doesn't work that way.
Just so creative.
I like quick fired
volume, his masterpieces.
So that's who stands out for me.
- That's great, and then
last quick question,
biggest mistake a creator can make?
- Making the decision
on the piece of content
for the audience before they put it out,
aka, a nice little graphic there.
But that's it.
- Yeah.
- That's it time's up.
I gotta play by the rules.
Thank you so much bro.
- Thank you, I think
they wanted me to ask you
a couple prices on some card,
just 'cause you have sports cards.
- Okay.
- I have a few cards, I'm gonna
ask you to guess the price
and then it will be good.
- Guess the current price?
- Yes, guess the price of the card.
So here's a let's see,
2008 Serena Williams.
Guess the price of that card?
- Eight bucks.
- 8.13, wow.
- That's fucking go!
- Okay, (chuckles) okay hold
on second one, second one.
Let's see, Cristiano Ronaldo, right here.
- 27?
- 11, 11.
- All right.
- Hey, first one was like
spot on, I got two more.
- The first one was crazy.
- That was crazy, that
was right on the money.
Okay, Michael Jordan bowls right here.
- All right, but that's
not a good that's a reprint
- This isn't original, this is
a reprint so this isn't like,
- And like a shitty
grainy company, 60 bucks?
- 25, 25.
- All right, all right.
- Okay, one more, one more.
Let's see, we got some Jets for you,
Sam Donald right here, 2008 game.
- Are these your cards?
- I bought these for this.
- That's fucking amazing.
14 bucks.
- Exactly 14 bucks, there you go.
- That's fucking go!
- Two out of four,
- I think 'cause it's numbers
you were both on the
money, that was great.
- I love it, the book ends,
all right brother good talking to you.
- Right, see yah.
- Stay well, that was funny. (chuckles)
All right let's rock and roll.
- What's up, Gary, how are you?
Oh my god, I'm so happy to be on the show.
Listen, I'm here because I totally respect
and I've been utilizing your strategies
from the 64 pieces of content.
And I actually blew up my business
and I wanted oo come on
and say thank you so much.
But I wanna give you a little context
on what I'm talking about.
Two and a half years ago,
I was looking at a wall in rehab,
and I didn't know how I got there.
16 years my marriage was failing,
and to complicate things even more,
my wife came down or was diagnosed
with stage four stomach cancer.
So my drinking escalated
as you can imagine,
and I got two young kids,
they were 10 years old at the time,
and I knew I had to
change so I went to rehab.
I got sobered up, and I came
out man I was so humbled.
My parents helped me get a 25 foot RV.
I'm living in this RV.
And I don't know what the
hell I'm gonna do with myself.
I'm sober but I'm just completely like,
what am I gonna do?
I found this product
that I absolutely love.
And I started watching
motivational videos on YouTube.
And Gary Vee, you're all over
social media, absolutely.
So man, I bought your book "Crushing It!"
And I'm like, dude, this guy's
got exactly what I need, right?
So I'm utilizing the strategies,
I'm loving everything!
And then you come out with
the 64 pieces of content.
I start blasting out all my stuff
all over TikTok, Instagram
you know the deal.
And I absolutely crushed it.
So my question to you Gary is,
my story, my struggle, when is too much?
I don't wanna just keep
saying my story over and over.
But I know that I wanna
help people, right.
So another thing is,
I'm in this RV, I'm laying in the top bunk
and I come up with this
thing of positivity.
So the Positivity Gangster,
I create this shirt right?
I wanna help people.
I want to help people with positivity.
I listen to you everyday man.
You're like a legend, you're
a legend to many of us.
I want to give back by selling this shirt,
the Positivity Gangster T-shirt.
I wanna donate all the profits
to help feed the hungry.
What you did with the all in challenge,
what you did with the TikTok marathon,
I watched it from bell the
bell, you're making an impact!
You're doing amazing things and I just,
that's what I wanna know,
what can I do to add value to you Gary?
- Brother, you can bring value to me
if you just make yourself happy, the end.
Like do good things, make yourself happy.
I'm good, I don't need anything from you.
I need you to, you getting
value from my free content
and that bringing you happiness,
which then allows you to
bring somebody else happiness
is disproportionally the
best gift you can give me.
I don't need shit.
- Well, utilizing your
64 pieces of content.
You changed my life Gary,
you showed me what to do,
I took action,
I grew that business to over
a million dollars in a year.
And it just keep going
and going and going,
and I just, I have so much
gratitude for you, man.
- Makes me happy men.
- I got your shoes NEELA!
- I did brother.
- I love you.
- Thank you.
I love you back men, keep pushing.
- It would mean the world to me
if the Vee fan would come together
and help me feed the hungry
with the Positivity Gangster T-shirts,
you can go to my website.
I'm donating all the profits.
Thank you so much Gary.
- Take care yourself stay well.
Let's keep rocking and rolling.
- (gasps) I was told I was number four!
So I'm just relaxing
on my hands. (chuckles)
- Hi Alex, how are you?
- Dying right now. (laughing)
- How are you, how are you?
- Oh my God, your team
is amazing. (laughing)
- Thank you, thank you.
- I've only just been
waiting six years for you,
Gary, it's okay. (laughs)
- Thank you so much, well
we're here let's do it.
- I know you always like to
know how people find you.
So I thought I would show you.
This is how I found you
six years ago. (laughs)
And just before I go into my question,
I just need to tell you,
four years ago, when I
left my last agency job,
I was at TWA and I
started House of Social,
I cross the street for I live here,
and I wrote you a longest
email and I just cried so much,
because I just knew that if
I was to put into practice
everything that you teach and you pass on
that I was gonna be okay.
My mom is my hero.
But you came right after, and you've been,
I just want you to know,
you've been with me for
these past four years.
And trust me, I know that
four years it's like baby,
it's like I'm only just scratching
these little surface that I'm on.
I'm so excited for what's to come.
But I just want you to know,
you have been with me
for the past four years.
And if I had to wait six
years to come on here now
to talk to you,
the universe knows what's
happening. (laughs)
- I love it, thank you so much, Alex.
- Okay, so my question to you is,
I know how amazing you are
at having the capability
of looking at a product and a service
and find innovative ways of
how to package it or sell it.
So that's where I'm coming from
with the angle of my question to you.
So what do I do?
I do a mix of consultancy and education.
Those are the two things
of House of Social.
Consultancy by consultancy packs for me,
they're like hourly packs
to make it real simple.
Because here in Dubai,
things are not as mature
as maybe Europe or the US.
So I got my consultancy, okay,
and then I've got my education.
So since four years I will do
master classes, short courses,
boot camps, what else do I do? (laughs)
Yeah, master classes,
boot camps, short courses.
I do a lot of free stuff.
So my last masterclass in January,
now my master classes are free.
So it will be like 200
plus people that will come.
I do quarterly free meetups.
And of course, there's like a ton
of free content out there.
So giving for me it's the
thing that comes more natural.
So I knew that I had to give,
give, give, give give, also,
also because here in this region,
it's still kind of a new concept. (laughs)
So now to even give you
more of a timely context,
since we got into quarantine,
which for us here in Dubai
was since March 8th, 5th,
so I think it was earlier than you guys.
I knew right away that I
had to go into the lives,
that I had to do live content.
So I've been doing this show
called Mini class with Alex.
And I started back from March 5th.
So I think we're going to
Work 50th episode real soon,
three times a week.
Now I've scaled it to twice a week
because here things are
almost at 90% Normal.
Okay, so I'm still continuing.
But Gary, I don't know
what happened, something,
and it took me a while to
understand what was happening.
My mom clocked it much earlier than me
something crazy, magical, special happened
with these live sessions.
I was just coming in, showing up.
I dance, I'm loud, I'm just--
- You're yourself.
- Yeah, like, yeah, like this was not--
- Everybody's everybody's at their best,
when they're themselves.
- Yeah, but because it was just myself.
I didn't really understand
what was happening.
Because I was--
- Makes sense, you were in your zone.
- I was just in my zone.
And I was just being me
that I have been for the past four years,
when you maybe come to my master
classes and my boot camps.
But I don't know, maybe I was
just a little bit more extra,
because now I'm stuck at home.
And now we've got all this time
and I just wanna be with my people.
I just wanna be with my community
because now I cannot run my events
like I can't be with them.
And something really beautiful
and magical happening
in this kind of like month and a half,
where the DMs and the emails
and the feedback was like,
this is like your energy,
your energy into things.
And at the same time I'm
teaching like Facebook ads,
or email marketing, or
how did you storytelling,
like all these like topics.
And so something really magical happened.
I was never asking for a cell.
I was never going in like hey, do my.
Nothing, I was doing
that through Facebook ads
and my email marketing.
So and the magical
thing that happened was,
so my mom is my financial manager.
She was one that said to me,
what takes you a month,
what takes you two
months to do in revenue,
you've done it in a month.
So that was like mind blowing to me
where I wasn't even asking
for anything in those lives.
And I would wake up--
- You were bringing value.
That's jab, jab, jab, right hook.
literally the way this started.
Pull up the book.
- Yeah!
- It was that jab, it was that Alex,
that book is a micro of
giving and then asking.
That's the micro.
That was a book I wrote six years ago
on how to do that in content.
What you're radiating right now
is you were living that in the macro.
It's how I live my macro.
Like, I am so focused on this community
that's watching this right now, period.
Right, the end.
- Yeah, and I thought that,
the most the most mind blowing
thing for me was like, wow,
I thought I was giving before
because I would do a masterclass
that I used to charge.
And then as soon as I got
a good deal with the venue,
I stopped charging and I
was doing a masterclass
that 200 people would
come and it was free.
So I thought I was giving
value and I was like--
- You were giving with
expectation of a conversion.
- Probably yes, yeah.
- You were subconsciously,
you were giving,
it was giving with the
expectation of a conversion,
or the deep short term
hope of a conversion
versus giving in perpetuity,
and knowing good things will happen.
- Oh yes.
- And that's what happened in part two.
- Aha, right.
So to get to the actual
question, which is.
Well, it's two questions and then one ask.
I launched an online academy last year,
because I knew I had to
take my stuff online.
It's online courses that
are as interactive as I can.
And then there's bi-weekly
mentorship sessions.
Here in this part of the world,
online learning is still not as mature,
as maybe Europe or the US.
So I knew I was gonna have
a difficult time with a conversion.
My two questions to you are
when I see the huge volume of people
that are coming and getting it for free,
And when I look at the price,
and by the way,
my question is not necessarily on,
hey Gary I want more people to buy,
it's more about,
I think I am missing something
on how I am packaging my
online academy business.
Because what I've learned
is what people want the most
is access to me on a one-on-one
because as you know--
- It's always access, it's always access.
- It's always access,
and even when you do
group mentorship sessions
is kind of okay.
But then it's when you get one-on-one
that you really get
real deep with a person.
So I am learning--
- Because people are getting
value for their money,
information, just information,
you're competing against unlimited stuff
that's free on the internet and You Tube.
- I know, I know which is why--
- Well, that's life, that's the bargain.
- So my question to you is,
when I look at how I've set up my academy,
which is there's three
tiers of membership,
like you can do three months, six or 12,
you get access to my online content
and you get bi-weekly mentorships.
When people say we really,
really, really want
is the access to you.
- Raise the price on the access to you.
- Is there something that I need to do,
on how to repackage this?
- Raise the cost of access to you.
- But if they're not if there's not much
of a higher volume in converting.
Ah okay, I get you!
So they'll get more one-on-ones with me
so I have to put in there
one-on-ones with Alex more.
- And charge more.
- And charge more, and still
giving out access to the online
academy like to the-
- Look, everybody can do
it how they wanna do it.
My favorite thing is put
out all the content for free
and then the access to you
becomes $10,000 an hour eventually.
- Other people wanna do conversion,
where they film once and
they charge $99 a month.
Everyone gets to do it
the way they wanna do it.
My favorite point of view is kind of,
content is so commoditized
on the internet,
there's so much I mean,
all my content is free.
I'm competing with you.
- And let me tell you, I
sometimes give away my courses.
This is what's crazy, I
give away free course--
- But the biggest part of
that sentence was sometimes.
- Yeah, yeah, so just give it all away,
so give it all away?
- They're funnels,
you give it away with the
hope that it gets them hooked,
and then they pay you.
Versus just building so much value
that then a small group sees the value
in doing one-on-one with you
and you charge a premium for that,
they're getting value
and everybody else is.
You're building a bigger opportunity grasp
but that's how I like it.
And I don't get to be right.
I just get to be me.
- Gotcha, so they'll pay,
okay I totally get you, I see.
Now my mom would kill me if
I don't ask this question.
Everybody wants Alex's energy.
How do I sell my energy? (laughs)
'Cause my mom wants to put
Alexes in a bottle and sell it.
- By doing one-on-one
consulting at a higher price.
- Okay,(laughs)
- Got it?
- But if people are not hundred,
if there's not a lot of volume of people
converting for an online
academy where the prices,
I feel so low, I'm guessing--
- It's because the product's not valuable,
because they can get information for free.
- Exactly, and because they're
not really then getting
what they really want, which is--
- Correct.
- Got it, I get you.
(Alex moaning)
Okay last question.
- No listen--
- It's not even a question,
it's not a question!
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- I'm going in for right hook,
you gotta let me do a right hook.
- Well, I know you're going to,
you're built on doing
short term conversions.
- Am I really?
- Yes, that's what we just
spent the whole time talking about.
(Alex laughing)
- Okay, would you consider being a guest
on my Mini Class with
Alex, as you live show.
Would you consider it?
- Not until you show me that
you've become a marathon runner
versus a sprinter for over a year.
- And what do I need to do?
In practicality what do
I need to show you that?
- Put out content for free and
stop selling low cost things
and then start selling
$2,000 an hour or $5,000.
Makeup the math in access to you
and do that for a year and show me
and then I'll consider it.
- So I have to raise my prices higher
for my one-on-ones and
everything else free.
I got that, I can do that. (laughs)
- Love you Alex take care.
- I love you, thank
you so much, thank you.
- All right let's keep this going.
Sure that one brought
some value to people.
Hey Sharon.
- Hey.
- How are you?
- So nice to meet you,
I mean I'm good I hope you're good too.
- I am, thank you, where are you from?
- I'm from India.
I'm from Delhi in India.
- So great.
- So first of all thank
you for all the motivation
and all the content
that you have out there,
and thank you to Zen and to Dustin
for helping me out on the backside.
Thank you so much.
So my question mainly
was what is your advice
for a college student
who wants to get better at time management
and upgrade their skill sets.
Be it like a workshop or an online course?
Because for me--
- How do you learn?
- Right now I'm in
college, so that is how--
- No, no, no, no, no,
no how did you learn?
How do you learn well reading,
listening, being taught,
like how do you learn well?
- A mixture of both generally.
- I mean, the answer is two things.
One, you have to figure out how you learn,
two you need to figure out that experience
is much more interesting
than being a student.
So, you want to get, you know,
A, why, and then C, we
need to audit the judgment.
And what I mean by that is,
why do you think you're not
good at time management?
Why do you wanna get better at it?
Why are you judging yourself on that?
- I mean, because at the end of the day,
maybe I'll just spend
half of the day relaxing,
not doing much stuff,
scrolling through Instagram or YouTube,
and then even if it's a small activity,
it will persist for maybe a day or a week,
rather than what I can
finish in a few hours.
- Well have you considered the fact
that you may not wanna
be doing those things?
- A little bit, but, yeah,
to get to college, you have
to complete certain things.
- I understand, but I don't think
you're gonna get better at it.
I don't think you like it.
- Yeah.
- Everybody procrastinates
shit they don't like,
and everybody does things that they love.
- True.
- I've got a million things
I'm supposed to be doing,
I'm procrastinating them
because I don't like them.
But I'm up to two o'clock
in the morning last night
looking up sports cards
on eBay 'cause I like it.
- But then I mean,
how would you find something
that energizes you?
Because right now I'm just 19.
So, I know I have a lOng way ahead but--
- Which is amazing, for me
I tend to like to ask people
to really slow everything down
and try to figure out,
like really audit the
last 19 years of your life
and try to figure out what you like.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I had another question for you,
like I have this interest in--
- Real quick--
Okay, go ahead, go ahead,
go ahead, go ahead.
- I have this interest in digital media
and that's why I'm doing a media course
right now in college.
So, I want to know how can
you find a skill or a job
that you can enhance
throughout your college life
so that when you are out
there in the job field.
you are able to learn more
rather than going from
the bottom of the pyramid,
learning that skill from the bottom.
- Skills are a commodity,
and actually not so valuable.
I think what you should focus
on is interacting with people.
- All right.
- I think if you're
spending time in college,
what I would challenge yourself to do,
is to meet as many people as possible,
and really get much better
on your people skills
and empathy and compassion
and listening and friendships.
Because the skills are,
college is not gonna teach
you the skills of real life.
- Yeah, true.
- I know it's true.
Like listen, many have
to go through college
and get a degree to go into
the field that they like,
but you don't learn about,
you know no matter how much
somebody trains for war,
once the war starts, it's different.
No matter how many videos
you watch on YouTube
about playing basketball,
when you get on the court
and somebody elbows you in the chest,
you're not playing basketball.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You understand like school is not built
for what you're asking for,
what you could do,
though, on the flip side
is use this time to really
start to learn people,
because teaching can be done
in a lot of different ways.
And consuming information
and gathering information is great.
But the reality is you can do that
outside of the school system,
outside of university.
Life is so much about actually doing,
of course you can learn certain skills,
doctors, lawyers the lot,
like you have to memorize those things,
you have to learn those things.
But like doing,
if you're talking about business
that gives you marketing--
- Practice makes it better.
- Yeah, I mean, reading
about running Instagram ads
is different than running them, right.
Reading, you know, thinking
about how to make a podcast
versus actually making a podcast.
like you know, you know, I just.
- Getting into that
faculty and learning more.
- I get worried that people
think like I hate college
or this and that, I hate debt.
I hate that people think it's a ticket
to a skill or happiness.
There's a lot of great
things about college,
people mature, it's an age group,
18 to 22, 17 to 23.
You're a very different person.
Unlike this thought that
you're gonna take a course
on project management, or on advertising.
I mean, you know this.
What they're teaching in college
for advertising is antiquated.
- Yeah.
- You have to do.
- Okay.
- All right.
- Thank you so much, Gary.
- You're welcome Sharon, take care.
- Take care, bye bye.
- Good bye.
(slurping tea)
- Hey.
(baby crying)
- Hi, Gary.
- Hi!
Hi Kelly, who's this little one?
- Yeah, he's Lucas.
He's the reason I've been watching you.
- I love it, hi, Lucas.
- And he's teething, I apologize now.
- We're all teething Kelly,
we're all teething in one way or another.
(Kelly laughing)
- Yes you can, go ahead Kelly.
- Well we're we're based in southern Spain
in a place called Marbella,
I don't know if you've heard of it?
- I have, I grew up in the
wine business, so yeah.
- I was wondering whether you
had any connection with wine.
But yeah and my mom has a
property management business.
She's had it, she's been in the
property management business
for 10 years, but she's
only had her business
for the last three.
So it's quite new.
And it's kind of like
a two prong business.
She looks after properties
of people that own them,
but don't live here.
And then those people also like for her
to rent them out for holiday season.
And I've been helping her
since I've been on maternity
'cause there's one thing that you said
about being online in 2020,
that if your businesses not online,
then you're basically dead in the water.
And I just thought,
I've got to help my mom,
I've really got to push her on that side,
because that's not her
strength and to be honest,
it's not massively mine either,
but I can learn and I can help her.
Especially now I've
got well a bit of time.
I've actually got two children under two.
But so my question is,
we want to expand the company,
we have about 24 properties at the moment,
we want to get more properties.
But how can we do that
when everyone is after the same thing?
And we don't really know where they are,
there's hundreds here, but
we don't know who they are
and who they belong to.
- When you say there's 100 years,
sorry little guy, Lucas.
When you say, when they're
after the same thing,
I just wanna make sure
I fully understood you.
- I mean, when every other
property management company
is after the same client, they all want--
- You gotta be better.
- Yeah, but how, how do
we promote ourselves?
'Cause the way I was
thinking is Facebook ads.
- That is one.
- But we need to employ
people to do that for us.
because I've had a go before lockdown.
And it amounts to nothing.
But I mean, I know I haven't put
any effort into it really, I have--
- Well good news, anything
you don't put any effort into
always amounts to nothing.
- Well yeah, I know, I mean,
it's a lot to learn, isn't it?
- It is, that's why it's
good. And that's why it works.
You what else takes a
lot of effort, push ups,
and if you do it every
day, you'll get muscles.
- Yeah, well, I mean,
what I was thinking with the Facebook ads,
is because it's not
particularly my forte either,
maybe it's better to pay
somebody else to do that for us.
- The only problem is, if you
don't know how to judge it,
then you might waste money that way too.
And I kind of like the
idea of you learning.
You're so young, you learning
that skill is something that--
- I'm not that young.
- Kelly you're that young.
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm a little bit
younger than you, I'm 40.
- Kelly you are young as shit.
(Kelly laughing)
- I mean you're not fucking Lucas young,
but 40, like you're the minimum
we live another 40 years
like you're young and learning this skill
right now is very important.
(Lucas crying)
It's all right Lucas.
Look listen.
Lucas Lucas listen to me,
you're gonna clip this video one day,
and you're gonna use it
on your social media.
(Kelly laughing)
Lucas, this a big piece of
content for you brother.
Yeah Lucas, yeah Lucas,
that's called likes baby.
(Kelly laughing)
All right so, I think that,
I think you should learn it.
I like the way you ask the question.
I like your energy around it.
I think you should learn it.
Because putting in those 15 to 20 hours
is something that's gonna pay
dividends for you forever.
- Yeah, do you think that's
the only way we should go?
because other people have
said no, we should do flyers,
but I'm thinking that is too
old school and a waste of paper
because we don't even know
where the properties are,
and the people
(Lucas crying)
- Facebook will be paper.
Do you think that's the only way?
Is that the only way we can go with this?
- No such thing as the only way.
It's an extremely good
way to go right now.
Expense, prices on ads
is super low, super low.
And I think you should absolutely.
It's an incredible, good use of your time.
you learning it, even if
it fails for your business
'cause you didn't figure out the creative,
it's still, it's still going
to be the best thing you do.
You're not gonna learn shit,
printing a flyer and putting
it in people's mailboxes.
But you'll learn an obnoxious amount,
if you put 20 hours into
learning how to run Facebook ads.
You literally go to Google,
and you go how do I run Facebook ads.
- Yeah, I mean, I have started
it and I did run a few.
But yeah, I definitely need to learn--
- And remember Kelly, it's the ad.
It's the picture of
the video that's going,
you could put a picture out
that does nothing to do picture or video
that gets you 10 leads.
So it's not the skill
of knowing how to do it.
That's the commodity.
Anybody can learn how to ride a bike
or dribble a basketball.
It's about being a BMX superstar.
It's about being Isaiah
Thomas, you get it?
You have to be good at it.
So it takes reps.
- 'Cause we've also
started Instagram as well.
Again, that was something
that we didn't have.
Do you think that we--
- Facebook, Facebook ads?
- Okay, only Facebook, do you
think that's the only thing
we should be on, Facebook only?
- I think it's the first, I
think for property conversion,
Facebook just, it crushes.
But Instagram, building up your
personalities also can work.
- Okay, we will do both.
- Good luck.
- Thank you so much.
- Bye Lucas.
- Will you follow us on Instagram, Gary?
- We can, what's the account?
- Oh, it's some holiday
rentals, there it is.
- Got it, just to make
sure I do it afterwards.
Dustin also just I have an emergency.
So I'm gonna have to
wrap up in nine minutes.
Thank you, Kelly.
- Thank you so much, bye.
- Bye bye.
- Hi!
- Hi Chelsey, how are you?
- Good, it's tea with Gary Vee.
(laughter)
- Where are you from?
- I listen to you
every single morning.
I'm from Biloxi, Mississippi.
It's a little town.
- I know it.
- About an hour outside
New Orleans, yeah. (laughs)
- I just got you, what's kicking?
- I'm just gonna give
you a quick backstory.
I know you have to hurry up.
I am from Mississippi and you always joke
about moving back to Mississippi,
which I did during the quarantine.
I moved out to Los Angeles
about over two years ago.
When I lived in Mississippi,
I was working for a corporate company,
and I loved working there.
I was in the marketing department,
but I just wanted something more,
I wanted to work for myself.
So I went the entrepreneurial route
and joined my oldest brother,
I have four brothers out in
Los Angeles to open a company.
So kind of dropped everything
and moved out there on land
and loved living there.
But it was hard working with
family, very hard (laughs)
Which I didn't think
it would be that hard.
So he and I are very different workers.
He's very money-motivated,
which is great, but I'm
more family oriented,
which he is too but I feel like my family
and people who are close to me,
their relationships are way more important
than any amount of money.
And I think that working with him
really showed how much we were
like different in that way.
So now I moved back to Mississippi--
- Do you feel that he was unfair to you,
and chose money over your relationship
as a brother and sister?
- Yes sometimes, yeah.
- Do you think, and I
mean this in a good way,
Do you think it's possible
that he was treating you professionally
and that you were looking
for some level of nepotism
or like a little bit more compassion,
even though you two were putting on
the jerseys of doing business,
or do you think he was, like
do you not like his morals
and the way he thought about things?
- I would say it was
more morals, which I--
- Okay, honestly we don't even
need to go deeper than that.
I just wanted to make sure
that you weren't caught
in youthful entitlement,
because then that's your vulnerability.
And I just wanted to double click on that.
You've given me what I needed.
Let's keep moving back.
You're back in Mississippi, and boom?
- Yes, I'm 28 years old.
So I've tried a few different things.
I'm still working for him full time.
I moved here because I'm actually
moving to Boston in August.
So my boyfriend lives in Boston.
I've actually never been to Boston,
but I'm moving there.
And I'm in this situation now
where I'm trying to decide,
do I stay on this route
of working for my brother,
I'm still working for him.
Or going back into the corporate world.
So I'm almost at an opposite.
And I love working for myself--
- What about the obvious third one,
which you just answered?
You don't like corporate,
you don't like working for your brother.
Why don't you try to figure something out
that isn't going back to something
you already know you don't like?
- Yes, and that's what I'm trying to do.
Finding out my passion and
trying different things.
- What about doing a lot of
homework, five hours a day,
on your favorite 25 to 50 small
businesses and entrepreneurs
in the Boston area and
reaching out to them,
and maybe working for
someone that you admire,
build yourself up, save some
money and go from there.
- Yeah, and that's where
I hit a few roadblocks
is the money situation of
course just like everybody else.
- Of course, of course.
- Working for myself,
I had no benefits I didn't
have any type of savings
to fall back on.
So I had a few things come up
when I was in LA, and I--
- Can your boyfriend,
I'm sorry to interrupt,
but can your boyfriend, hold
it down for a little bit.
Does he give you some breathing room?
- Well see, I don't like to,
I don't wanna say handouts,
but I don't like to rely on anybody else.
- By the way, I respect
the shit out of that.
- Yeah, he's offered, I mean, he's great.
He's offered he said, hey,
I'll pay half your rent.
'cause I'm actually not
going to live with him.
I've decided I want to live on my own.
So I'm moving to a place I've never been,
and I'm gonna live on my own.
We're not gonna live together.
I just wanna make sure
that I like Boston for me.
- Good for you.
- I want to make sure that I get settled
and find my own kind of path or way.
- Chelsey I'm impressed, I'm impressed.
(Chelsey laughing)
- Yeah I mean I would say L.A
- Whoosh you wanna stay alone.
Do you have any penny girl?
Look at this yeah.
Looking to stay independent,
had a good situation
sounds like financially,
with your brother but
didn't believe in it.
Like you've got a lot
of things going for you,
like don't want to move in with him,
because you wanna make sure
like you like it for you.
Like you've got a lot
of good shit going on.
- Thank you, thank you.
- So let me tweak it a little bit,
like don't go back to corporate,
you know you don't like that.
I think you go into,
now first of all you might like corporate,
you might have just not
like that one company.
So that's another thing.
- I feel like I'm gonna
try a few different things.
I mean, I have a recruiter
who's helping right now,
he probably thinks I'm crazy.
So I'm like, I'll try
pharmaceutical sales,
I'll try real estate.
He's like, you're all over the place.
I'm like, I just want to
find something that I love.
And I want to do,
I don't wanna, 'cause I work remote.
When I pick up my computer,
I'm almost miserable.
It's like every single day.
I don't wanna even look at my computer.
I wanna do something
that I'm excited about.
And I love marketing 'cause
I love talking to people
face-to-face, like that gives me energy.
But the last few years I've
been behind the computer
doing project management,
and I'm like, I can't look at
the computer anymore. (laughs)
- You need, people retail might be good.
Like listen.
- Yeah.
- Do me one couple of favors.
One, 28 is a tricky year.
People start getting
impatient around this time.
So don't get confused, you're super young.
You have like five more
at best to find it.
Number two, definitely
put yourself in a position
to be around people.
- Okay, yeah and I mean that's
what I do struggle with,
especially being in the south,
I mean I feel like I'm
behind in a lot of ways.
When I come back here everybody's like,
I mean which is great,
they have their house.
- Oh you mean everyone's
married, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I'm like, I don't
even want that anytime soon.
- You just took the words
right out of my mouth.
You're not about that life.
- No, not at all.(chuckles)
I mean, which I think is great.
Don't get me wrong I
think to each his own,
whatever makes you happy.
But I want fun, and that's another thing
about going back into corporate,
is I know there's a lot of security in it.
- Hey Chelsey, hey Chelsey,
- Yes.
- There's a Michele Gina who
in the comments I was reading.
She said Chelsea hit me up,
thank you so much, Dustin.
There you go Chels.
- Oh, there we go. (chuckles)
Thank you Michelle, for sure.
- She's on Facebook Michelle,
You have a Facebook comment,
you're @michelemastro.
I'm gonna assume that's
Twitter and Instagram.
I'm sure you'll find her,
Chelsey, but like, there you go,
- Thank you, (laughs) appreciate it.
- Get yourself around people.
- Yes.
- And don't do the normal 28
year old thing and get worried.
- Okay, yeah, and I think
that's what I'm doing.
And I mean, I listen
to you every single day
I got hooked to you when I heard you
on a podcast or something.
You said, entrepreneurship
is lonely as fuck.
And I was like,
oh my God, who is this guy? (laughs)
Because it is I mean, I moved
out to LA thinking that,
I would have this whole different life,
and I got there and it was just so lonely,
for the first six months.
But I'm so thankful for going through that
because now I'm like, I can move anywhere.
- You're strong.
- I can talk to a brick wall. (laughs)
- After talking to a brick
wall just do me one favor.
Just don't get a job with the Patriots
because then we're finished.
- (laughs) Okay, I'll
tell my boyfriend that,
I think he's a Patriot. (laughs)
I'm a Saints fan.
- Oh I know it.
- All right, thank you so much Gary.
I really appreciate your time.
- Take care.
- Bye.
- Sorry to cut it short everybody.
I've got something I need to address
and so I have to bounce.
But I wish everybody a great, great day.
Hope you're well.
Thank you so much for watching.
I can't wait to be back tomorrow.
We'll go at it.
Love you guys take care, bye bye.
The people that are gonna win
over the next five to seven years,
are going to be very comfortable
in control the fucking chaos.
(energetic music)
You don't love the process.
This is dreams we're talking about.
Dreams require sacrifice.
All of your actions have to map to it.
(trills) Backpack, backpack backpack.
Nobody gives a shit
about where you grew up.
The whole game is scaling the unscalable.
It's fucking hard work,
it's being respectful,
it's being a good person.
Do that, that's just a good idea.
It's there, the flipping is there.
This house right here, it is $400 to make.
I stay in my lane,
like real fucking tight,
but you can't be crippled.
Everybody who's judging themselves.
You're looking at what's
in front of you right now.
You're losing 'cause
you're laying in your bed,
looking at somebody's fucking
glamorous photoshopped picture
of them doing something
cool, and you're envious,
and you're jealous and you're impatient.
And it's crippling your upside.
Let me just say one more time,
if you're confused what I just said.
I say put your fucking flag on the ground
of who the fuck you are.
- Whoever provides the
most value always wins.
You're entering the greatest
five year window of your life.
My only answer to me and everybody,
it's just like try shit.
Take your business down
and go work for an apparel
company for 10 years.
Nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work.
So you better get your speed up.
You better work harder.
You better work smarter.
(energetic music)
If you can't Google stuff,
you're not gonna be able
to do anything that I'm telling you to do.
GaryVeeTV, my middle celt.
Check me out, I hope you enjoy it.
(energetic music)